We have always been afraid of the dark.
Ancient ancestors of mankind built fires to
chase the shadows away, to keep the thick,
black mystery of night from encroaching on
their fragile little homes with all of the
teeth and claws it hid within its depths.
From the time we were small children, we knew
to be nervous when the lights went out.
We beg our parents to leave the hall light
on or plug in a nightlight, praying that a
tiny sliver of illumination will protect us
from the monsters we just know are salivating
beneath the bed, scratching against the closet
door, waiting for us to close our eyes.
We pull the blankets tight over our heads,
heating the air with our panicked breaths
and reminding ourselves that the shadow in
the corner of the room was just a rocking
chair or a coat rack.
We pretend it’s the truth.
But there’s a reason we fear the darkness
as much as we do.
It’s inherent.
It’s a memory passed down from generation
to generation ever since we first learned
how to scream.
As adults, we try to tell ourselves we’ve
outgrown those childish fears and night terrors.
We know better now.
But you still run up the darkened staircase
as if something’s chasing you and your heart
jumps into your throat when you hear a sound
after midnight.
Call it el cucuy, the kludde, the boogeyman,
or a thousand other names; we all know there
is something lurking in the dark.
And it knows us too.
D-Class 080-1 was pulled from his cell one
afternoon and brought to a containment chamber.
He knew the drill by now.
They would send him in and he would encounter
something bizarre, horrible, and potentially
deadly.
Maybe he would emerge traumatized, maybe he
would lose a limb, or maybe he would never
come back out at all.
A security guard opened the door and instructed
him to enter.
It wasn’t an ideal situation, but he really
didn’t have much of a choice.
And so, he walked inside.
Dr. Smith called to him from outside the room,
asking him what he could see inside.
It was pitch black, and he couldn’t see
a thing, and he told the doctor as much.
But then…the hairs on the back of his neck
prickled.
A chill rippled down his spine.
He had the distinct feeling that something
was looking right at him.
Watching.
Waiting.
“Did you just let something in here?”
He asked.
“It feels like something’s watching me.”
“No, D-080-1.”
Dr. Smith responded.
“We did not let anything into the room.”
The man’s hands were shaking, and he could
feel sweat beading on his forehead.
That couldn’t be true.
He wasn’t alone in here.
There, in the corner!
There was a black mass, large and somehow
even darker than the rest of the room.
He could feel its eyes on his, boring into
him.
His heart thudded in his chest and he felt
like he might be sick.
He tried to take a step back but his ankle
folded under him and he collapsed to the floor.
“What do you see?”
Dr. Smith asked.
The man struggled to find the words.
“This giant blackness, like someone just
standing in the corner.
Oh God, it’s looking right at me!
Let me out!”
He climbed to his feet and felt his way along
the wall until he reached the door, and began
to pound against it with his fists.
The Doctor refused to let him out until he
described the being’s appearance.
“It looks like a figure, hunched in the
corner.”
“Is it a human?”
Dr. Smith asked.
Though he knew it was too dark for the doctor
to see, he shook his head.
“It’s too big to be a human.
It’s still looking at me, Doc, still staring.”
Though he should have had adrenaline pumping
through his body, he felt suddenly sleepy,
almost unable to keep his eyes open.
“Move closer to it.”
Dr. Smith ordered.
The D-class obeyed, though he swayed on his
feet as he walked.
“Its eyes look like vapor, just staring
at me.
Like it wants me to do someth-“
At this point, he fell to the ground again,
suddenly silent.
Dr. Smith called out to him again and again,
but the man did not respond.
When the research team opened the containment
chamber several minutes later, D-080-1 was
gone.
He was lost to the thing that waits for us
in the dark.
He was lost to SCP-080.
This was the first in a series of tests that
a Foundation research team, headed by Dr.
Smith, performed in order to better understand
this shadowy figure and determine whether
or not it has a physical body of any kind.
When the results were determined to be unsatisfactory,
another experiment was conducted.
A woman referred to as D-080-2 was selected
and sent into the room.
This time, they would attempt to have the
D-class touch the entity.
Upon entering the chamber, D-080-2 remarked
on how dark it was, and how difficult it was
to see anything inside.
After several minutes, however, she noticed
something standing in the room.
When prompted, the only descriptor she could
give was that the entity had two eyes.
Dr. Smith asked her to approach the entity
and report any changes.
As she got closer, she became increasingly
drowsy and exhausted.
When she reached out to touch SCP-080, she
went quiet and did not respond to any additional
questions.
She was found asleep in the corner of the
containment room, and was immediately examined
by medical staff.
No adverse physical effects were found, and
an interview was conducted to determine if
there was any residual psychological impact.
In her interview, D-080-2 was noticeably distant,
her expression and tone of voice both described
as “spaced out.”
When asked about her encounter with the entity,
she became increasingly upset and began to
hyperventilate.
She screamed: “It just stared and stared,
not moving but I felt something!
I was on the floor and they were all over
me.
They’re here!
No, they’re trying to take me away, back
to that thing.
I won’t go back!
You can’t make me go back in there!”
At this point, she lunged across the table
and attempted to attack Dr. Smith.
She was removed from the interview room and
later terminated.
A third experiment was conducted, using a
man referred to as D-080-3.
In order to counteract the entity’s tranquilizing
effects, he was given a powerful amphetamine
at a dose that would keep a person under ordinary
circumstances awake for at least 36 hours.
When he entered the room, like all the others,
D-080-3 saw a shadowy figure standing in the
middle of the room.
He was told to stand still and watch the figure,
and report anything unusual that he might
notice.
After ten minutes, the subject became frightened
and demanded to be let out of the room.
He pounded on the door, and attempted to wedge
it open.
When he failed to open the door, he lunged
at SCP-080 and attempted to hit it with his
fists.
He promptly slumped to the floor and went
silent.
His dead body was found in the room after
the experiment, and an autopsy determined
the cause of death to be a severe heart attack.
The researchers who entered to retrieve the
body felt unsettled as they did so, reporting
a feeling that SCP-080 was looking directly
at them the entire time.
Following the conclusion of these experiments,
the research team was able to draw several
conclusions about SCP-080.
It causes debilitating drowsiness in anyone
who enters its containment chamber.
After thirty minutes of exposure, anyone who
is observing the entity will involuntarily
fall into REM sleep.
If there is any light in the room brighter
than a standard children’s night light,
the entity will disappear.
This should be treated as a containment breach
if and when it occurs.
After conducting their experiments, Dr. Smith
and his research team began to experience
highly upsetting dreams.
While many of the staff began requesting appointments
with the medical team, Dr. Smith refused to
discuss the nature of his dreams with any
on-site psychologists, insisting that he wasn’t
going to let some silly nightmares get the
better of him.
As the weeks wore on, however, he became increasingly
withdrawn.
His colleagues noted dark circles under his
eyes, and noticed his near-constant consumption
of coffee that far surpassed anything they
had seen from him before.
He seemed as if he was terrified of falling
asleep.
One day, the exhaustion caught up to him and
he fell asleep at his desk.
Everyone in the building heard his screams,
and when a security guard eventually shook
him awake, his throat was so raw from crying
out in terror that he was coughing up globs
of blood.
Dr. Smith begged to be given an amnestic,
to help him forget what he had dreamed about,
forget all of his dreams, but the request
was denied.
He was placed on an indefinite leave of absence
and sent home.
Two days later, the research team was given
a somber report: Dr. Smith had leapt off a
bridge.
Following Dr. Smith’s tragic demise, the
rest of his staff were given notebooks and
encouraged to keep dream journals during the
course of their research in order to track
the psychological impact of studying SCP-080.
Additionally, they were required to turn these
journals in to the site psychologists for
review, particularly if the dreams became
especially disturbing or violent.
The following are excerpts from some of these
dream journals.
Research Assistant Megan Vaughn:
“Last night I dreamt I was lying in my bed.
Not my bed now, in my apartment, but my childhood
bed with the baby pink sheets and the quilt
my grandmother made.
It felt so real, every detail.
My dollhouse in the corner, my big teddy bear,
my tea set, and my closet.
I was lying on my side, with my head facing
my closet.
I used to be so scared of that closet.
Every night I would sob until my dad checked
it for monsters.
I couldn’t go to sleep until he did.
But in my dream, I knew he hadn’t checked.
And I just knew there was something in there
waiting for me to close my eyes.
So I didn’t, I just stared at that closet
door and I waited for it to open.
I started to hear this scraping noise, like
dragging something sharp across a wooden surface.
Over and over again.
But the door didn’t budge, no matter how
long I stared at it.
All the while the noise just kept going.
Scrape.
And the sound of soft, raspy breathing.
But the closet stayed shut.
Eventually, I rolled onto my back, and there
it was.
On my ceiling, hanging over me with its upside-down
head and round, open mouth, an old woman with
long stringy hair and fingernails as long
as my arms.
She was scratching on the ceiling, and waiting
for me to look.
I couldn’t move, I could just stare up at
her as she took two of those long, long fingernails
and slowly inched them toward my eyes…and
then I woke up.
I’m scared if I go back to sleep, she’ll
pick up right where she left off.”
Dr. Owen Kohli:
“I’m swimming in my family’s pond, and
it’s a beautiful sunny day outside.
I can feel the sun’s heat on my skin, and
the crisp cold water cooling it every time
I dip under the surface.
I decide to swim down toward the bottom and
dive for rocks, and when I come back up, suddenly
it’s dark.
It’s the middle of the night, and the water
doesn’t look so clear anymore.
I can’t see the bottom.
I can’t see anything around me at all.
And I feel something slither against my leg.
I kick it away, but I just feel something
else on my other side.
Slimy and quick.
I can’t see it, but I can feel that it's
much bigger than me.
So I start swimming toward the edge, trying
to get out before something worse happens.
Then I feel this sharp pain, like a hundred
needles stabbing into my back.
It hurts so bad I see red, but I keep swimming.
I reached the edge and I try to pull myself
out but I can’t, there’s something on
me and it’s so heavy I can’t get out.
I look over my shoulder and I can now make
it out: it’s the biggest leech I’ve ever
seen, and it’s latched on to me.
I can see it pulsating, swallowing.
It’s draining me.
And I feel so weak all of a sudden, dizzy,
and I look down at my hands and they’re
shriveling up right there, my fingers pruning
as I feel the blood being pulled out of me.
My vision blurs and my head tips back and
I’m sinking down into the water as the leech
keeps sucking.
It pulls down into the muck at the bottom,
and everything goes dark.”
Researcher Kathy Levine:
“Okay, in my dream I was in my old house,
back when I lived out in the woods.
No cell reception and no neighbors.
I was in the shower, washing my hair I think?
It’s hard to remember the details.
I don’t remember the details of dreams very
well, but I’ll do my best.
This part I do remember: I heard this sound,
like footsteps coming from the floor above
me, that quiet thudding sound coming down
through the ceiling.
I turned off the water to listen better, and
there it was again.
Definitely footsteps.
Someone was in my house.
I threw on my clothes and slowly snuck out
of the bathroom, and made my way to the front
door.
I don’t know why, I just knew I needed to
get out of there.
Just when I opened it, I heard the footsteps
behind me and I turned around, and there was
this man there.
Huge, like seven feet tall, massive tangled
beard, wild eyes, and holding an axe.
We stared at each other for a long time, and
he just smiled.
Like he was so sure he was going to kill me,
and have a lovely time doing it.
I ran out of the house and into the woods,
and I could hear him coming after me.
Branches hit me in the face and cut up my
arms as I ran, and I just knew I had to get
away.
But then I started to get that feeling you
get when you run in dreams, like your legs
don’t work.
Like you’re pushing through water.
I was running as fast as I could, but I wasn’t
going forward at all.
And then I felt a hand grabbing my hair, yanking
my head back, and the blade of the axe slicing
across my cheek.
He whispered in my ear, and his breath smelled
like rotting flesh.
And I’ll never forget this next part, he
said “We’re not done playing yet.
I’m going to take you apart in tiny pieces,
and save your head for last.”
Dr. Robert Gray:
“I was sitting on the couch, next to my
wife.
We were watching television.
I turned to ask her a question, and she was
staring at me with these dilated pupils, so
big her eyes looked all black.
Then she opened her mouth, to speak to me,
I thought.
But it got wider and wider, and it had no
teeth, just this expanding tunnel of pink
flesh that started to suck me inside until
my head disappeared into her mouth and I began
to suffocate.
I haven’t been able to look my wife in the
eye all day today.”
Other dream journals were less detailed.
Research Assistant Matt Guerrero simply wrote
“My dog ate me,” while Senior Researcher
Barbara Bradley wrote: “I was stuck inside
my fish tank, and my fish were feeding me
human flakes.”
No matter how frightening or absurd the dreams
detailed were, all the staff reporting experiencing
feelings of intense stress and panic while
having them, and after waking up.
SCP-080 is contained in a 4m x 4m room with
a small antechamber on the south wall, providing
researchers with access to the space.
On the other side of the north wall, there
is an observation room where researchers can
view the containment room through a window.
The window is outfitted with thin blackout
curtains, which release when the observation
room door has fully closed.
No one may attempt to remove SCP-080 from
its containment at any time, under any circumstances.
No light sources may be brought into the room,
and no more than one seven watt incandescent
lightbulb may be lit inside.
Additionally, no objects may be brought into
the room that can be used to hide SCP-080
in any way.
Anyone who breaks these rules will be swiftly
and strictly disciplined, and may be subject
to termination.
Following Incident 080-1, the containment
measures have been reevaluated and additional
measures have been proposed.
During this incident, two senior researchers
entered the observation room and released
the blackout curtains.
Certain that this was a safe way to observe
SCP-080 without being influenced by its adverse
effects, the two remained in the room for
forty minutes.
At this point, the two fell asleep.
It is unknown what exactly happened after
this.
However, after this incident, all staff suffering
from anomalous nightmares reported having
their first restful night of sleep since the
research had begun.
It was as if the entity’s appetite had been
temporarily sated, and it had released the
rest of the team from its influence.
In light of Incident 080-1, a member of the
research team suggested that a D Class be
left in SCP-080’s room once a month in order
to feed it, and protect the rest of the team
from psychological harm.
After some debate, and opposition from the
ethics committee, this proposal was approved
by the O5 Council.
Now, the entity is kept on a regular feeding
schedule, and the staff’s dream journals
have been relatively uneventful ever since.
It turns out that sometimes the price for
a good night’s sleep is just a little bit
of human sacrifice.
Now go check out “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885
- Find Him” and “The Secret at the Bottom
of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” for more anomalies
of a truly nightmarish nature!